buenos días a todos a mí me gustaría
comenzar con una pregunta han ido alguna
vez a una sala de escape
bueno está muy de moda para quien no las
conozca se trata de un juego de aventura
en el que un grupo de jugadores
encerrados en una habitación han de
lograr salir o escapar en un tiempo
prefijado para lo cual deberán resolver
varios enigmas
que no se preocupen quienes no hayan ido
todavía a una sala de escape porque
pueden pensar en un sudoku un
jeroglífico o cualquier reto de este
tipo podrían describir sus sensaciones
al ganar el juego
normalmente diríamos que se siente una
especie de euforia una impresión de
poder con cualquier reto es una
consecuencia de la adrenalina liberada
durante el desafío
esa es la sensación que engancha a un
matemático que la vive cuando encuentra
finalmente la demostración de un teorema
cuando observa por primera vez una
relación entre conceptos insospechada
cuando tras muchas horas haciendo
estudios de simulación el ordenador
ofrece resultados
y estoy segura de que ustedes al
enfrentarse a la sala de escape al
jeroglífico o al sudoku se han sentido
así es el latido de su vena matemática
esta buena matemática es universal y es
una lástima que a veces quede olvidada
simplemente por desconocimiento o por la
creencia errónea de que no la tenemos de
que es propiedad exclusiva de unas pocas
personas a las que les gustan las
matemáticas
hoy vamos a reflexionar sobre tres
cuestiones relacionadas con la
estadística para poner a punto nuestra
vena matemática la primera parada es la
importancia de los datos en la
actualidad los datos son nada más y nada
menos que la materia prima de la
estadística y datos podemos encontrar en
multitud de situaciones de hecho cada
vez más frecuentemente gracias a los
grandes avances tecnológicos que
facilitan la recogida de información
todos vivimos rodeados de datos
piensen por ejemplo en la información
que recopilan las encuestas de opinión
los resultados de unas elecciones o bien
en su día a día
por ejemplo cuando nos levantamos y
corremos la cortina para ver qué día
hace recabamos información meteorológica
quizás esta fotografía es demasiado
optimista pero podemos ganar un poco de
realismo
también cuando cocinamos un arroz o una
paella intentamos que queda en su punto
y aplicamos nuestra experiencia previa
de otros cocinados con el fin de
intentar predecir el tiempo exacto de
cocción y que el arroz no se pase
o cuando lo pensamos como deficiente es
nuestro coche calculamos cuál es su
consumo medio de combustible cada 100
kilómetros y así podrían pensar en
muchas otras situaciones que nos
proporcionan datos
es más los aparatos que facilitan su
recogida han visto cómo aumentar su
demanda por ejemplo las pulseras de
actividad que registran pues nuestras
calorías quemadas pulsaciones cuando
hacemos deporte nuestros ciclos de sueño
etcétera
y los datos no solo sirven para
describir la realidad sino que nos dan
la clave para intentar pronosticar qué
va a ocurrir en un futuro claro está la
previsión basada en los datos puede
cumplirse o no ya que es imposible saber
qué va a pasar exactamente pero la
estadística nos da garantías para
acertar la mayoría de las veces bueno
cómo ven la estadística es un campo
peculiar dentro de las matemáticas
porque bueno pues porque en una materia
que se rige por la exactitud de sus
resultados incorpora un aspecto nuevo y
diferencial enlazar el azar nos llena de
incertidumbre y la estadística es la
única linterna que nos permite ver algo
en esa oscuridad
volvamos a las pulseras de actividad
bueno pues lo que sabemos es que esa
información que recogen es muy valiosa
para las empresas no solo las pulseras
sino que pueden pensar en otros ejemplos
porque pues porque la utilidad que
pueden tener los datos es luego la
facilidad que dé a las empresas para
conocer el perfil de sus clientes
averiguar qué atrae a los clientes de
sus competidoras o por ejemplo estudiar
el patrón de comportamiento de las altas
y las bajas en los servicios que ofrece
la estadística es una herramienta
poderosa para conocernos y conocer el
mundo que nos rodea
eso sí las conclusiones de la
estadística han de analizarse muy
cuidadosamente como vamos a ver ahora
con varios ejemplos
la primera pregunta que nos vamos a
plantear es qué animal es más hábil a la
hora de resolver un puzzle un pulpo o un
gato doméstico
bueno una pregunta muy muy profunda
como ven aquí el profesor trap y esquí
nos ha tomado la delantera y ha diseñado
una prueba o un experimento para
comparar la habilidad de ambos animales
en las mismas condiciones
el profesor afirma que el pulpo es más
inteligente están ustedes de acuerdo con
él no parece una comparación muy justa
verdad las condiciones del estudio si
bien son similares para ambos animales
favorecen muy claramente la atracción
del pulpo frente a la del gato esto
quiere decir que el experimento no está
bien diseñado y por ello las
conclusiones del profesor carecen de
valor otro pequeño ejemplo podría ser el
siguiente
como decía irónicamente berna shop se
puede probar con estadísticas que las
personas que usan paraguas son más
gruesas más saludables y viven más
tiempo que las otras
es decir usar el paraguas engorda bueno
pues hay que tener en cuenta el contexto
a principios del siglo 20 el paraguas
todavía estaba considerado un artículo
de lujo es decir que la diferencia en
vida no era debida al paraguas sino a la
calidad de vida de aquellas personas que
tenían paraguas en la época
bueno como esta tras la versa sobre la
estadística creo que no debemos dejar
pasar la oportunidad de visualizar
algunos datos aunque sean anecdóticos
la siguiente pregunta que nos vamos a
hacer es si las películas de ahora son
peores que las de antes
y si queremos saberlo podemos buscar
datos en internet hoy en día hay datos
sobre prácticamente cualquier tema
en esta gráfica se ha recogido una
colección de películas seleccionada por
una página web cada círculo azul
representa una película así que tenemos
información acerca de su año de estreno
y la puntuación que le han otorgado los
internautas
bueno qué me dicen ven a alguna relación
entre la puntuación y el año pues parece
que hay una asociación entre los títulos
más recientes y las puntuaciones más
bajas porque si nos fijamos en las
peores calificaciones
son las que obtuvieron las películas de
entre 1990 y 2010
sin embargo que películas han
considerado en esta página web
evidentemente no son todas las películas
que existen y por tanto esa colección de
películas no tiene por qué representar
bien las características de la totalidad
sin más que representar cuántas
películas se han recogido por año se
puede ver que no todos los años están
igualmente representados en concreto
tenemos muchas menos películas antiguas
que recientes y podría ser que las
antiguas estén escogidas precisamente
por su calidad ya que son los usuarios
de la web los que actualizan la lista
con sus películas favoritas
aunque no es imprescindible tener muchas
películas sí deberían ser
representativas de todas las que hay por
eso como esto no ocurre en el ejemplo no
podemos extraer una conclusión general
acerca de la calidad
bueno pasemos ahora a una pregunta más
cercana
no vamos a entrar en el debate de
actualidad sobre si son más ricas las
marañuelas del banco o las de candás eso
puede terminar muy mal y además yo no
soy la persona más objetiva en ese tema
pero la pregunta que vamos a ver es la
siguiente como de conocidas son las
marañuelas bueno para ello vamos a usar
google trends es una herramienta de
google que nos permite ver las
tendencias de búsqueda de determinados
temas en esta gráfica se ha representado
el interés que suscitaron las marañuelas
a lo largo de 2019 y podemos ver que ese
interés estuvo comprendido habitualmente
entre 10 y 35 en una escala de 0 a 100
es decir que fue un interés medio bajo
no obstante vemos una semana totalmente
atípica en la que el interés fue máximo
de 100 distinguen qué semana fue fue
exactamente la semana santa cuando hay
un dato tan diferente es preciso
averiguar si se trata de un error o que
lo ha originado en este caso la
explicación viene de que
tradicionalmente las marañuelas han
estado vinculadas con la semana santa
ahora bien en muchas ocasiones nos
interesa resumir el comportamiento de la
mayoría de los datos por ejemplo el
interés medio por las marañuelas en 2019
nos permite sintetizar todos estos datos
con un único valor pero qué impacto
tiene esa semana atípica en el interés
medio
para ver su influencia podríamos volver
a calcular la media con todos los datos
salvo el de la semana santa y veríamos
como el interés medio cae y de hecho
podemos encontrar ejemplos en los que
esa caída es tan grande como sea como
queramos
afortunadamente hay métodos para paliar
esto porque imagínense las consecuencias
tan nefastas que puede tener este hecho
cuando establezcamos las conclusiones de
nuestros estudios y éstas dejen de ser
válidas simplemente por el impacto de un
único dato
esos métodos que limitan la influencia
de las observaciones atípicas o erróneas
se llaman métodos robustos por la
solidez de sus conclusiones incluso en
situaciones como esta
por último la evolución de la
estadística no sólo comprende el
desarrollo de nuevas técnicas para
analizar los datos sino que a veces la
novedad reside en tratar nuevos tipos de
datos
algunas veces han hecho una encuesta
citas telefónica
yo les voy a proponer una muy breve no
de las que duran cinco minutos más otros
diez minutos intentando convencer a el
teleoperador de que no nos va a vender
nada y menos a la hora de la siesta
bueno en este caso nos preguntan cuánto
creemos que vamos a reflexionar durante
estas charlas y tenemos un pequeño
formulario con cuatro opciones de
respuesta creo que voy a reflexionar
mucho bastante un poco y nada
la primera pregunta que nos puede surgir
es si esto es suficientemente
informativo el hecho de que sólo haya
cuatro opciones de respuesta limita
mucho mientras que naturalmente nos
gustaría que nuestras respuestas
proporcionarán mucha información
además está clara la diferencia entre
por ejemplo reflexionar mucho y
reflexionar bastante
tienen claro cuándo clasificarían su
grado de reflexión en una categoría u
otra la distinción que pueda hacer yo
entre estas opciones de respuesta es la
misma distinción que puedan hacer
ustedes bueno hay una serie de
inconvenientes asociados a esta forma de
responder llamada escala likert
para solventarlos se pueden buscar
escalas alternativas
la nueva escala va a ser libre es decir
no vamos a tener que escoger nuestra
respuesta de entre una serie de
respuestas prefijadas sino que vamos a
gozar de libertad para construirla
parémonos un momento en este punto el
lenguaje natural es limitado y las
palabras que existen mucho bastante poco
no son suficientes para hablar de
infinitos grados de reflexión
pero si conocemos un lenguaje que tiene
esa capacidad
el lenguaje matemático
por tanto para dar nuestra opinión vamos
a utilizar un número con números y no
palabras
la primera idea podría ser dar una
puntuación de 0 a 10 donde el 0 se
identificaría con la expectativa de no
reflexionar absolutamente nada y 10 con
la de reflexionar mucho pero no les da
la sensación de que nos pedirían
demasiada exactitud para una valoración
que por su naturaleza es imprecisa pues
así es
la escala que vamos a ver ahora se llama
escala de valoración difusa libre y nos
proporciona una forma nueva de expresar
nuestra opinión aunque sea también
numérica
vamos a dibujar el rango de valores que
solemos utilizar para puntuar de 0 a 10
y la primera pregunta que nos haríamos
sería entre qué valores está nuestra
opinión
pongamos que por ejemplo pensamos que
vamos a reflexionar mucho pero quizás
podríamos reflexionar aún un poquito más
bueno pues podríamos dar el intervalo de
valores entre 8 y 9 porque son muy
buenas puntuaciones pero no incluyen la
máxima
a continuación pensaríamos que valores
son compatibles en cierto modo aunque no
sea totalmente con nuestra opinión y
ponemos por ejemplo los valores de 7 a
10 bueno el dato que considera
conjuntamente estos dos intervalos se
llama difuso trapezoidal
trapezoidal
porque recuerda un trapecio
y difuso porque su forma de expresar
nuestra opinión deja de ser un número y
pasa a ser un número difuso un número
impreciso que está modelado a través de
una función
recordemos que los valores con los que
estábamos completamente seguros eran los
que estaban entre el 8 y el 9 bueno
pues les asociamos la máxima
compatibilidad con nuestra opinión 1
sin embargo no estábamos tan seguros de
los valores entre 7 y 10 aunque no
queríamos descartar los completamente
por eso un valor como siete y medio nos
puede parecer asumible pero no nos gusta
tanto como los que están entre el 8 y el
9 y si se fijan en el 7 y medio
la compatibilidad es 0,5 baja hasta 0,5
claramente esta forma de responder es
más complicada que las cuatro opciones
de respuesta que teníamos al principio
con la escala likert pero es mejor
para compararlas se ha llevado a cabo un
estudio con alumnos de cuarto de
primaria del colegio san ignacio de
oviedo
se seleccionaron varias preguntas de un
cuestionario internacional que evalúa
los conocimientos de los alumnos de ese
nivel en matemáticas en ciencias y en
lectura
el llamado teams piris y en el que se
basan algunas medidas que plantean los
países los distintos países en política
educativa
bueno tenían que responder utilizando
las dos formas las dos escalas y la
información que se ganó con esta nueva
escala fue mucho porque cuantas
respuestas diferentes podríamos obtener
con esta nueva escala tantas como
alumnos infinitas posibilidades frente a
sólo cuatro opciones que teníamos con la
escala inicial
es más los niños captaron muy bien el
espíritu del estudio y tras un breve
entrenamiento nos sorprendió mucho
constatar que tenía muy buena
disposición a aplicar esta forma de
responder y que sus respuestas eran muy
coherentes actualmente estamos
desarrollando técnicas estadísticas para
analizar datos de este tipo
bueno espero que estas pinceladas de
estadística les hayan hecho reflexionar
y darse cuenta de que el interés por los
datos está en auge y precisamente por
ello conocer algo de estadística nos
permite valorar lo que se nos dice y de
desarrollar nuestro pensamiento crítico
han sentido las palpitaciones en su vena
matemática
cultiva en la siempre que tengan ocasión
muchas gracias por su atención
[Aplausos]